buongiorno a tutti mi chiamo metto
moretti e sono coordinate un appunto
della repubblica popolare di bolzano è
un progetto di videogiornalismo che
attraverso infografiche visualizzazioni
di dati mappe interattive ha cercato di
sfatare il mito di un invasione cinese a
bolzano questo purtroppo anche grazie a
un team interdisciplinare composto da
designer giornalisti antropologi che
hanno collaborato per raccontare il
fenomeno attraverso tanti punti di vista
molto differenti ma soprattutto perché a
bolzano
c'era questa idea di lingua sede cinese
era una cosa che spesso accadeva
soprattutto camminando per strada
parlando di barco le persone solo per
tutto tutti i passanti da cinesi ci
stanno invadendo la cosa migliore che
sono veramente strana io vivo forzare
ormai da cinque anni e ansie reputo
busana nulla
le città in cui la comunità cinese
particolarmente integrata nel tessuto
sociale
vi faccio solo un esempio quando stavo
col treno quando uscite dalla stazione
troverete davanti a voi una serie di
chioschi che vendono booster autobus che
viene gen il cibo
diciamo tradizionale di quella zona il
primo proprio brivio è di proprietà di
angus young wii un ragazzo che è
arrivato dalla cina con della città
sei anni ha avuto con la tradizione in
un certo senso perché la sua famiglia o
ristorante cinese e lui è deciso invece
di interrompere come vorrebbe la
tradizione cinese li si vorrebbe che chi
continua a essere all'attività di
famiglia 12 tiro nella tradizione aprire
il sovrascorrimento perché lui già detto
nell'intervista di tali poste allora è
questa la rifiuto di schiavon segno di
integrazione concerto di invasione però
se sia effettivamente questa percezione
questo fenomeno di un'invasione esiste
da qualche parte deve essere nato è così
ben deciso di andare in qualche fondo né
aprire una finestra sua comunità cinesi
di bolzano per capire meglio chi sono e
perché di questo si è mossa la prima
cosa che abbiamo fatto molto semplice
sato prendere i dati a bolzano celustka
un po come l'istat
quindi è l'istituto di statistica locale
e masters ha detto subito i cinesi a
bolzano sono 633 su 100 5703
cosa significa significa che sono lo 0 6
per cento basterebbe questa slide per
dimostrare che lascia nessuna equazione
cinese almeno a livello demografico
però appunto abbiamo voluto cercare di
andare oltre a capire perché
e siamo ai ma tifosi a cercare i dati
della camera di commercio commercio sono
privati delle aperture delle attività
gestite da cinesi e dati gli effetti è
molto interessante a cavallo tra 2008 e
c'è un piccolo di apertura di attività
che arriva al massimo diciamo d'apertura
in un anno significa circa un negozio e
mezzo che per una realtà piccola come
quella di bolzano è effettivamente tanto
ma se andiamo a vedere poi il settore
commerciale nello specifico scoppia una
cosa abbastanza interessante ad esempio
su 441 bar a bolzano sono 51 sono cinesi
significa 12,5 per cento su 261
ristoranti solo 32 sono scesi quindi non
dici regolato del totale quindi la desco
ancora più interessante perché cosa
succede la zona sempre al 100 della
popolazione in qualche modo possiede
meno del 12 per cento dei pari a meno
del 12 per cento dei tratti quindi il
laterale veramente interessante forte ma
possiamo parlare certamente di grandi
imprenditori concerto di grandi invasore
e forse il nostro primo progetto
universitario per dire che ci esistono
grande imprenditore così abbiamo cercato
di capire ancora che fondò il perché di
questa percezione distorta insomma
questa invasione cinese
iniziamo avanti cerca le sue medie
locali effettivamente qualcosa di brutto
a galla soprattutto sulle pagine
dell'alto adige in campo ti diamo nei
locali del gruppo espresso che a cavallo
proprio del 2011 ha cominciato a
titolare in modo piuttosto ambiguo
quando si trattava di cinesi come
saprete spesso si leggono soli titoli
delle notizie noi magari tutto il corpo
della formazione e più chi scrive il
titolo non è lo stesso giornalista che
ha scritto l'articolo proprio perché
titolo una valenza anche quasi politica
e quindi ho fatto una bella selezione di
titoli sul tema dei cinesi usciti
intorno al 2011
questo è il primo cine sono prodotti lì
in mezzo ai binari è finito in
psichiatria
capisco che in provincia non ci sia una
grande
vitali ci sia molto da raccontare però
insomma sono youtube boxing pong
ma questo è niente in confronto a questa
questa è la prima volta in cui diciamo
promossa idea di una cena tambor sarina
in più vengono descritti nel titolo 150
quando latte viste le statistiche sono
diverse mappe lì dipende come si sa che
legalizzati basta questo mare tutti i
ristoranti e bar assieme numero cambiati
e questa è la prima volta che è promossa
insomma una scritta castelli ad in
acciaio town pochi giorni dopo
quest'anno al 13 marzo invece vanno
ancora rimedio pochi mesi dopo il primo
megastore cinese sfide negozi league a
torino allora usarla parlatene con
menegazzo rievocano scenario
diverso dalla realtà questo è meno per
dovere di cronaca va detto che si sono
tre che prima c'è anche il piano
inferiore quindi è un negozio grosso non
è certo un megastore però produce stesso
molto diverso dopodiché si passa andarla
ad un allarmismo quindi negozianti
bolzano troppi permessi cinesi con il
sottotitolo ci schiacciano nel corpo di
questa notizia poi c'è una dichiarazione
abbastanza epica ne dice il presidente
dell'unione commercianti che sarà
abbassato per tutte le pizzerie bar
ristoranti girare per tutta la zona
dopodiché paziente invece ora in una
notizia come questa sotto esame molti
batte proprietà cinese
adesso voi immaginate se ogni volta che
c'è un ispezione debba uscire una
notizia su quotidiano abbastanza
paradossale perché poi la news
non c'è neanche la sua un titolo messo
così e non dice niente se queste
iscrizioni sono anche bene o male
questa è la mia preferita è quindi più
diffuso forzando cioè cinese c'è allora
linea gente onesta di più lo si immagina
che a bolzano 1 su 10 si chiama il primo
nei 100 che insomma che c'è nessuno più
diffuso sia tra lo so secondo il terzo
il decimo con il più diffuso
se poi natale giornale tizia sul cliente
che cinese chen posto 38 subito dopo li
calabrese gilotta del posto 37 quindi se
va bene ma c'è un modo di fare
informazione un po ambiguo che produce
chiaramente un senso la percezione anche
di scorta di quello che quella città
di tutti i giorni questo quindi ci ha
motivato ancora di più nel fare un
progetto che cercassi rispettare in modo
puntuale usando dei dati questo concetto
di invasione cinese che quotidianamente
veniva si sentiva soprattutto per la
strada e questo esito che abbiamo fatto
q repubblica popolare di bolzano punti
che modo abbastanza ironico cerca di
trattare l'argomento ma chiaramente
anche non solo i nomi camente ma che con
i lati l'approccio è quello di creare
tanti piccoli performative dove c'è una
parte noto asciutta di testo e dei
grafici che aiutano a capire e
soprattutto la comunicazione diciamo
l'idea generale di mettere il visitatore
davanti alla sua inadeguatezza nel senso
che tutto quello che ne sappiamo sicilia
si fosse va messo in dubbio perché sono
spesso idee precostituite e quando noi
un esempio non si vede molto bene posso
sito si vede meglio ad esempio nella
prima sneijder mostriamo come la
migrazione cinese in italia sia iniziata
nel 1900 al cenacolo di paolo sarpi a
milano si è formata negli anni 20 quindi
la migrazione cinesi non è un fenomeno
robot
altra curiosità la grande maggior parte
dei cinesi in italia vengono tutti da
una piccola regione che si chiama
zhoushan la vedete la nato è questa qua
festeggia anche poco più grande della
lombardia ha la stessa popolazione
dell'italia
una cosa invece che bonzanini quando
sapevano e che il rapporto tra italiani
e cinesi a fonsai 07
tutto è un terzo rispetto alla media
nazionale
quindi tutte queste informazioni
importano le persone che dire ma forse
devo ripensare e rivedere un po in i
progetti rispetto a quello che i cinesi
in italia ma soprattutto questa mappa
interattiva si vede in cui abbiamo
aggregato i dati della camera di
commercio uno strambo di tempo diciamo
amica con animazione dove sono le
attività gestite da cinesi ed è evidente
che non esiste una certa anzi c'è una
distribuzione piuttosto uniforme su
tutto il territorio in più nella parte
bassa su questa cosa sul sito si vede
sicuramente meglio con i colori e ha
mostrato la tipologia di attività e
questo spiega anche perché nei due
minuti ci si sposa trichan all'apertura
perché quegli anni di cinesi han
cominciato a differenziare i loro
business quindi non solo padre
ristoranti ma anche minimarket e negozi
d'abbigliamento sanno dipendenza e così
via
i dati però io lavoro unico
quotidianamente o quasi con la
visualizzazione di dati
i dati dicono tutto ma dico anche niente
soprattutto quando si fa le tematiche
sociali e molto importante anche
mostrato le persone mostrare la
complessità che c'è dietro
semplicemente
ed è così grazie al lavoro
dell'antropologa siamo riusciti a fare
delle interviste qualitative dei ragazzi
cinesi
l'intervista è qualitativamente lo dice
molto particolare sugli incontri
preliminari e poi un'intervista aperta
quindi può durare anche ore in cui la
persona comunque si rilassa si sente a
suo agio e riesce anche ad applicazioni
quindi questi interviste riportano
semplicemente raccontare la storia della
persona ma riportano una complessita di
informazione che i dati non
riuscirebbero a trasmettere e quindi
dimostrare che c'è un bianco o nero
questi sono gli intervistati abbiamo ad
esempio lei che una ricercatrice
universitaria ma questo non è abbastanza
diversi lui e gli angoli il ragazzo che
adesso le borse e gli faccio vedere
giusto un registrato di queste
interviste così di fatto i miei arrivo a
casa in valigia intervento al ristorante
avevo le chiesi che non avevano ancora
vista avevo il colpo è completamente
tinti ma non tipo come adesso il dalla
parte di un colore dall'altra dell'altro
era un po che tutto completamente biondi
e anche quando mi parlavano sta che
diciamo con lo sono
sono entrato dentro non l'ho detto io mi
sono fermato deal alla porta fortuna in
massa appena entri dentro le serate dove
tutti mangiano e io a mia madre dice
inaspettato che ci sono insulti cose
così riconoscono più basso perché questa
è una differenza da occidente
i ciclisti della molto di mira a
guardarti negli occhi è una cosa che
proprio non è prestata e proprio per
abitudine che non molto di più a
guardarvi ri complesso quindi non mi ha
portato negli occhi e viene portato bene
alla faccia mi stavo guardando poi massa
come l'inter dopo 15 secondi mi vede
altro sguardo la foto di un uomo come
questo ha chiamato che cosa per il nome
e nicola zucchi che provvedimenti
mio padre si gira e mi aspettavo delle
gran botte ci riguarda si è messo a
ridere tipo c'erano altri suoi due tra
rigidi e deriso proprio non una risata
un po 6 nascosto proprio su dorata avete
fatta a fatta dal pubblico tanto di dito
puntato una lezione a volte sorprendenti
perché mi aspettavo invece una netta
nuova più grossa io penso che ovviamente
ad essi siano con serenità lizzati
soprattutto a causa mia che avete un
figlio si vede quasi più italiano di
cinesi in casa tutti i giorni tutti mesi
tutto l'anno non può che avere
ripercussioni su anche su quello che è
il tuo ruolo da genitore e questo invece
un altro video
scusate se vi sentite questo è un altro
video invece d'incheon una ragazza
carimati l'italia
nel senso che sa per l'italiano se vi
provata la scuola superiore ai 5 anni
canonici prendendo un po tutti altri
fitto alla scuola che di 110 e lode
ceramente ballo l'italia ma nel
frattempo mi chiamo amici sono nata in
cina sono in italia da quasi sette anni
ho iniziato a frequentare superiore in
italia e adesso sto facendo si sta
attento
sto studiando economia e proprio credo
centro pure tanti tutti i compagni sono
francesi perché di solito nostro anni
arrivata in italia da cinque anni è
quasi impossibile centrare non della
maturità
questo possiede bene anche dando
dell'insegnamento proprio ciò che ho
fatto in cina perché la sua cioè molto
severa quindi un giorno dalla mattina
fino a sera degli studi axway anche qui
per me è più facile costruire ok abbiamo
poi inoltre dopo queste lunghe
interviste qualitative quando era molto
stanca e ne ho approfittato della loro
stanchezza e abbia fatto le classiche
domande quelle più becere ballo pare che
nessuno altro lancio di fifa dal cinese
e l'abbiamo andati tutti insieme abbiamo
creato un video chiamato video
rompighiaccio perché poi arriva a metà
della navigazione alleggerisce un po
territorio
la comunicazione anche comprel estratto
vi faccio vedere il primo anno che ho
visto quando è tagliarsi sembravate
tutti lo fa pagare una banca
questi paesi e territori potrebbero
venire rubati da chiunque
vedevo gli altri apprezzare la lingua la
legge ronchi ha orari all'inizio o
schiavo po mi hanno pagato ai condoni
camerismo 300 libri e praticano ci sono
riusciti ma adesso si lavano stirano
amanti saluta pubblica tanti davano
piccini
poi in italia ha permesso a cercarsi
pubblico anche sulla base degli hotel
evitare preferenze miei personali
lasciare ricoprivo in cina ha detto
mandiamo fa delle 20
io no per la cina stimata sacra festa
dei bisogni maria dagati anche anche io
ho mai mangiato hanno fatto un cane non
mangia cane stessero prima volta locali
quando si avvicina di molto in seno all
it all anno in cina offre quadro goriano
i loro corpi dello stesso matri cina
quando hai proprio suo avvio dei fori e
quando cade cade le sue dai documenti
questi sono alcuni esempi
quello che abbiamo cercato poi di fare
con questo sito ecco un dibattito
pubblico locale perché il sito è online
girare il mondo ma in realtà la mente
stava parlando e localmente e c'è stato
un problema in india locali in qualche
modo ha migliorato il nostro progetto
nessuno ne ha parlato solo dopo cinque
mesi si sono accorti di noi perché lo
spiegel settimanale tedesco ha fatto
dedicato una pagina proprio sui media
cena nostro progetto
come potete ben immaginare a bolzano i
media locali sono molto sensibili ai
media tedeschi soprattutto quando tavano
filo e quindi in qualche modo si sono
sentiti toccati e ha dovuto pubblicare
il nostro progetto e ci hanno veramente
sorpresi questo è quello che poi
intitolato un alto adige e quindi in
qualche modo diciamo noi stranieri
siamo stati onorati e ci hanno sorpreso
ancora di più perché poi hanno pescato a
piene mani del nostro sito confezionato
i campioni come in chiesa cartacea sul
suo giornale e molto invece utile per
noi hanno fatto un post su facebook dove
c'è stato possibile misurare la qualità
dei commenti dei like dei vari follower
come potete immaginare di solito
successo sulla gente di bhatti in modo
molto animato simone litiga e follower
attuali generale periti che hanno sempre
ma sono tutti più o meno d'accordo
quando si parla di tematiche come
l'immigrazione
quindi cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo
confrontato la qualità dei commenti del
nostro preposte dell'arrivo al nostro
progetto con la piccoli commenti
relativi a lui può articolo contro i
cinesi in qualche modo che imparare in
modo ambiguo che sappiamo pubblicato su
fisco che sarà il 2011 quindi questo è
l'articolo dei propri
deve essere così anti cinesi e come
effettivamente si dividevano in modo
uguale tra prove contro il 40 40 per
cento sul nostro invece la cosa è stata
sensazionale perché i commenti positivi
era molto di più
quindi non ho la presunzione di dire
chiaramente che abbiamo fatto cambiare
opinione a una serie di persone quanti
invece siamo questo progetto è stato in
grado di polarizzare persone che avevano
una certa positività che sono in modo
positivo rispetto alle tematiche sociali
l'integrazione della comunità cinese
quindi per una volta pagina pagina
facebook della tua l'igiene ha ospitato
un dibattito che parlare in modo diverso
anche dell'immigrazione e
dell'integrazione
dopodiché altra sorpresa il progetto
viene premiato adatta giornalismo aula
da barcellona acquisto ritirando il
premio e ha colpito perché è stata una
giuria internazionale potesse è sempre
stato un tema così locale mentre ti
lamenti sia la metodologia che l'impatto
avuto sono stati molto interessanti
c'è un poche ore dopo vengo chiamato da
una giornalista dell'alto adige che vi
vuole intervistare perché vuole
documentare come è andato il progetto io
proprio l'occasione al volo e senza
troppi giri di parole di scrima che del
progetto si devo ringraziarli perché in
un certo senso delle grazie a loro che
siamo riusciti a fare questo progetto
dall'altro con i giornalisti loro hanno
una responsabilità di trattare certi
argomenti e spesso questa responsabilità
viene presa un po la leggera lei ha
capito immediatamente cosa mi riferivo e
anzi era assolutamente d'accordo con me
quindi contentissimo del fatto
l'intervista addirittura sull'alto adige
parlando in qualche modo di loro e della
loro responsabilità nel creare questo
fenomeno
torno a casa felicissimo il giorno dopo
apre internet e questo è quello che fu
questo purtroppo è un amaro finale ma in
realtà se leggete l'intervista è
perfetto è bellissima il problema è che
prima ti scrive titoli non ha perso
occasione per rimarcare questo fenomeno
della cena a un di bolzano quindi
nonostante il finale un po amaro
vorrei lasciarvi con questa non c'è la
citazione scusate ma per quella dico
così a voce una citazione di playoffs
che ha scritto un libro molto
interessante che si chiama information
dai informations fa un parallelo tra il
cibo e informazioni se siamo quello che
mangiamo
siamo anche quello che leggiamo quindi a
mangiano aggiornato nei molteplici
informazioni sull e scritte per
informarci e non per intrattenerci o
farci che cari le cosiddette minori